nothing is more contentious in Israel's
relations with the international
community than its settlements like this
one F rat in the West Bank just a half
hours drive from Jerusalem
my guest is its mayor Oded Reviva who
rejects international condemnation of
the movement and says he has a perfect
right to be here but with the new Trump
administration in office can he really
expect unconditional support
[Music]
or Deborah VB welcome to comp exam thank
you in the space of three days your
government authorized more than three
thousand new housing units and
settlements in the West Bank East
Jerusalem my largest increases in years
have you no concern for your
international reputation well I think
it's something that had to be done quite
a long time ago the American
administration dole the American
administration was definitely against it
and the Israeli government at the moment
is trying to catch up we've had to be
done you had to as EU put it seriously
undermine the prospects for a viable
two-state solution that had to be done
did it I think the two-state solution
that the Europeans are trying to talk
about is something that every day that
passes we're going further away from not
just because of what Israel is doing but
mainly what the Palestinians are no just
because but partly because listen
they're two partners of the game and
reality has stronger powers than making
resolutions far away in Paris where we
don't know if the government there is
going to succeed in Ex elections or not
but the overwhelming majority of
countries on this planet condemn your
settlements and have done for decades
the use as they're illegal and obstacle
to peace are you prepared for the
isolation now that's going to follow
this move the threat of isolating keeps
on appearing time after time and I even
saw you using it with your interview
with Naftali Bennett and I think he gave
you endless examples as to where Israel
is not isolated where Israel is actually
prospering why people are coming here to
invest why people are coming here to see
how we are he did the who do you think
supports your settlements who out there
in the rest of the world do you think
supports your settlements I don't think
it's a question of supporting the
settlements or not I don't think the
settlements are the obstacle for peace I
think we had two prime ministers
although they are according to the UN
Security Council in there were 14
countries from different parts of the
world almost every continent in the
world who are out against them yes they
were out against them and then they are
past opposing resolutions people
understand today that the only obstacle
for peace are the Palestinians it's not
decided people understand them all
around the world
they do they understand that your
settlements are an obstacle to peace no
they hear you really go on an obstacle
to peace it's there look at the website
of any EU country pick it up it's there
the settlements are illegal and an
obstacle to peace is our Security
Council resolution 2/3 3/4 declared the
settlements a flagrant violation of
international law and you say these
people are accepting that the
Palestinians are to blame they're not do
you live in an alternative universe I
don't need in an alternative universe
I'm trying to answer a question the
settlements are not the obstacle for
peace we had two prime ministers
offering between 92 to 96 percent of the
land and it was refused if you talk
about these settlements and the amount
of questions that you're asking about
the settlements
you're forgetting to tell your viewers
that all the settlements in Judea and
Samaria in the State of Israel which is
smaller than New Jersey which is one of
the smaller countries in it in the
United States or smaller than Wales for
the Europeans and all these settlements
don't amount to four percent four
percent of the occupied territories
disputed territories Judea Samaria each
with you use whichever politically
correct term you want that's not the
obstacle for peace the obstacle for
peace so what are the International
Court of Justice the UN the Red Cross
and almost all the countries on this
planet are they all biased against you
why why do they see things differently
from you I do you think you're the only
one who's the keeper of the sacred truth
no I'm not the only one and I'm not sure
that they really see the reality some of
them have never come to see it so I've
never never come to see the religion of
my neighbors and lots and lots of have
and some of them are bias and some of
them are prejudice and some of them have
changed their opinions after they have
come here all the countries that back
the UN resolution are they all biased
against you Britain France Russia China
you know but Bob Zealand Malaysia
they're all biased against you they're
not all biased against me so why did
they vote against you then
the Brits voted against and a day later
they condemned John Kerry's speech
wasn't which was against the settlement
so they didn't condemn it they took
issue with the fact that he talked about
the right-wing government they did not
condemn it let's stick with the
it was the Reviva we were trying to
stick with the facts and each one of us
has different sets of fact and each one
of us tries to spreads different facts
in order to tell a good story at the end
of the day just come back from America
maybe you brought some alternative facts
like Donald Trump back we know that
there's only fake news there there no
facts there but the United Nations
they've passed resolutions and I hear
what they pass but sometimes these
resolutions are against the reality
against understanding the problems of
the people living on the surface of the
earth and refusing to understand that my
Palestinian neighbors are coming out day
after day saying that they'd rather be
part of the State of Israel than rather
than of the Palestinian Authority which
has proven since 1993 in endless
examples that they are corrupt that
they're bankrupt and they're the ones
who are supporting terror so you can say
that we are the obstacle for peace but
the truth is that the Palestinians are
the ones for the obstacles I said you've
just returned from the United States you
were there at the inauguration of Donald
Trump he seems to have a very different
view about settlements than his
predecessor Barack Obama so now you
think the gloves are off and it's build
build build as many settlements as you
can is this the policy now I don't think
that's the policy I think the policy is
that there's going to be a meeting in
the beginning of February between the
new elected president and the Israeli
prime minister understandings will be
reached agreements will be reached and
then we'll be able to know what's going
to be the policy of this well your
deputy mayor of Jerusalem has already
jumped the gun he said the rules of the
game have changed with trumps arrival we
no longer have our hands tied as in the
time of Barack Obama now we can finally
build that's your deputy mayor of
Jerusalem you don't share that view he
is not my deputy mayor I think we've all
due respect to the city of Jerusalem
things need to be decided between the
heads of the two States Prime Minister
Netanyahu mcgunn you see different
people you know that's the beauty of it
you have an opinion on this I have an
opinion so I said my opinion is that I'm
waiting for my prime minister the one
that I elected to go and fly to the
United States meet the elected president
understand from him how does he see the
region how would he like to see things
reach understanding and with that go
ahead my personal agenda it has nothing
to do with how the Israeli government is
going to act at the end of the day you
trust
Trump to protect the settlements to
change the policy on settlements
you trust him I don't know yet who is
the new President of the United States
you were invited by his close circle
that is right and it was my pleasure in
my honor I don't know what I don't know
it was an honor but you don't know who
he is
it was an honor to attend in the
ceremony I don't know yet he's standing
on all the issues which are on stack I
do know that the people that he's
nominating are people that have lived
here learned here studied here know the
reality as it is not from a satellite
dish coming with ideas which have no
connection to reality or whether they're
practical or not and in that respect I'm
more hopeful with the people that he's
dominating so you try to trust him do
I'm more hopeful but you weren't so you
trusted
well I'll trust him after I know exactly
what he's going to do and what stands in
between his agenda and our agenda and
where is he going to lead the world I
think in that respect giving trust to
somebody that I don't know anything
about his policy I didn't have to make
that decision I don't have a right to
vote in the United States that's a
question you need them to ask in America
did you also talk to American Jews
who've been steadily losing support for
the subtle movement in Israel I've said
them I've talked to many Jewish people
in the United States I know the 62
percent according to J Street the
American Jewish oppose when I am NOT
Jewish organization but are using their
line are you saying I'm saying J Street
have got a problem with the facts and
the source of information you have a
problem with Stephen Cohen whose
research professor at unions Hebrew
Union College uses that on survey after
survey American Jews are opposed to
Jewish settlement expansion you have a
problem with him as well he's also
director of the Berman Jewish policy
archive at Stanford University different
people can have different opinions about
what's happening here the Jews in
America are entitled for their opinions
their giving it's the surveys he reads
the survey I also hear what you're now
reading out okay they are entitled for
their opinions from over there this time
I'm Jewish American people who are
extreme white right-wing who think that
we should be much more a violent and
oppressive against the Palestinians
giving suggestions from far away is
something
that is an out can be done but this
decisions need to be made by the people
who live in the reality so I hear what
they're saying I understand what they're
saying and there is wrong as all the
other countries who oppose your
settlement II I'm not saying there I'm
not saying that they're wrong I'm saying
I chose to live here I have an extremely
peaceful relationship with my
Palestinian neighbors after they come
and have coffee in my house they were
arrested by the Palestinian Authority
under the accusation that they were
sitting and negotiating peace with the
Zionist enemy they're my peaceful
friendly neighbors is the Palestinian
Authority who tries to put them in jail
and to keep their mouths shut
mr. it mr. Aviv II if your settlement
expansion leads to violence if there is
an explosion of violence as a result of
this will it have been worth it
the settlement expunging I think the
equation that you're trying to draw is
not a right one if we got answering a
question I'm trying to if we govern our
policy by threat of violence and terror
then there is something wrong with us if
we are people that go by the law if we
think that what we do is justified
legally then we shouldn't be frightened
of terrorists it's not just here in
Israel the same applies to the American
government so your opinion you do the
right thing
your this is what you're saying you are
doing the right thing the irony is that
the more you build up your settlements
the more Palestinian homes you destroy
don't you know we don't destroy any
Palestinian homes
that's according to bets Allah your own
human rights organizations are not my
own human rights organization is Raley
there is really there are a lot of
Israel here there on the ground you say
people don't come and see what's
happening better bets elem is on the
ground at that
but salem is here but salem is funded by
American organizations they have a
political agenda and they have been
proven aligned on it they have been
proven time after time to be inaccurate
at the end of the day 4% of Judea and
Samaria is built with Jewish homes
another six percent is built with
Palestinian homes the whole of Judah and
area only 10% is actually built area mr.
Revere houses are being destroyed
besides Jewish homes which are built by
mistake on mr. Regan mr. Revere
when the Israeli human rights group
B'Tselem reported last August that the
spate of demolitions carried out by your
Civil Administration was in full swing
it said in the space of just a week and
a half last August
you demolished 20 homes and 13 other
structures in Palestinian communities
including in the West Bank
leaving 53 people including 25 miners
homeless I'm wondering what kind of
government destroys homes where children
are living and throws them out onto the
street that's what kind of government
are you that sounds heartbreaking it
sounds devastating but but what you have
to understand what's the but so let me
complete my court man sir you have to
ask yourself where these houses built on
land which is owned by these private
individuals whether these houses were
built with building pyramids whether
these houses were built connected to
infrastructure or its acts of violence
done using children as prisoners in
these acts of illegal building and just
like families using children as
prisoners children tend to live with
their families mr. Vivi maybe they maybe
they do in your settlement as well and
you call that they're being held
prisoner Tim I've seen your shows you're
an intelligent person don't undermine
the other side they've used hospitals to
launch missiles from we're not there a
candidate again I give all dozing
Palestinian homes where children are
living and throwing children under the
street and I'm asking don't you ever
have a twinge of guilt about that sort
of situation doesn't it ever give you
pause for thought I didn't realize you
were so dramatic but I will get back to
situation is dramatic the situation will
be big the situation is dramatic because
innocent kids
are being taken as victims and as
gunfire to have this battle these houses
should have never been built where they
were built and just like the Israeli
government the militias houses within
the smaller Israel where they're being
built without building pyramids with
kids living in them because that's not
justifying and not obtaining to the law
so the same applies to these houses that
you're trying to make Israel is such a
monster demolishing these houses the
people who are the monsters in this
equation are the people who are taking
kids were taking six people sick people
as victims for they're launching
missiles for them putting them in houses
which shouldn't have been built mister
Reviva just stay with the facts because
just two months ago
Israel's High Court of Justice had to
issue a blunt reminder to your
government in respect of the omona
settlement reminding it that the
obligation to honor court rulings is not
a matter of choice it is essential to
government by law to which everyone is
subject as part of the values of Israel
in other words when a court says remove
a settlement remove it that High Court
should even have to remind the
government that that is its position
shows how little your government cares
about its own legal system cause it does
there are countless examples where your
government and the settler movement
ignores court rulings so that's why I'm
proud to be a resident of this state and
I'm proud of my Supreme Court and I'm
proud of my government and there is a
balance become part of a government that
ignores Supreme Court it doesn't ignore
in 2010 we had another example in 2010
an Israeli Court ordered the demolition
of two buildings in the settlement of
Beit el which had been built private one
private land and what five years later
under the buildings were still there and
what happened five years one another day
later what happened the day later the
two houses were demolished yeah why did
they prevaricate for five years they
were only demolished when the court told
them enough get rid of these how long
have we got you want to in this show go
through a legal file a legal proceeding
that lasted for five years and you want
to know why it went for five years it
went for five years because there were
different arguments there were differ
the peels there were different attempts
to change the decision because every
time the coke gives you a decision you
don't like you fight it
and you know that and you tell the
Palestinians just knuckle down have your
buildings okay although Tim you're being
not accurate with the facts as long as
it a I've given you effects and I'll
answer live in fact as long as you clay
according to the legal rules and within
the court system and you have an option
to file another petition and you have an
option to file another appeal and when
the government realized that there were
no more legal ways to go and make these
two houses stay in their place the
government demolished them just like
they demolished Palestinian houses and
if a Palestinian house wants to stay on
the ground and thinks he has legal
ground he can go through a legal process
and fight it until the courts say you
have reached the top level of appeal
idols in history VV mister VV there have
been decades of discrimination against
Palestine that's also a loser that's
also effectively yeah I don't know I'm
waiting for you to tell me where the
stack is that Israel is that
discriminating country you don't you
don't know that I don't know that you
don't know that in 2003 the official
report on the causes of the Second
Intifada led by Judge Theodore said that
government handling of the Arab sector
has been primarily neglectful and
discriminatory you didn't know they said
that the state did not do enough for try
hard enough to create equality for its
absence or to uproot discriminatory or
unjust phenomena you are you did your
hair you did your homework and you can
quote find a quote about every single
argument decision was then official
government inquiry into the Second
Intifada but the fact that that's what's
written doesn't turn it into a fact okay
the current government has dedicated
endless amount of money in order to fix
errors which happened in the past I'm
not trying to clear all the errors I've
made in the past but you have to
understand again that there's another
side to the equation
take example you want to Jews from the
mayor of Jerusalem when he gets elected
and he sees how neglected where their
Arab neighborhoods of Jerusalem
his number-one decision is that the
first light railway truck will lead to
bet huh Nina and Shuafat Arab
neighborhoods and where will they end in
Hadassah and Karin hospital so they will
have direct access to the hospital what
happens in this first round of violence
in the last Intifada the Palestinians
the people who live in bed Hanina and in
traffic go and burn down the light
railway and its station so go and do and
how neglected that large Rambla is and
what happened when you had fires the
Palestinians recently the Palestinians
came and helped you put them out
precisely so we've got good examples
which I want to promote and which I say
that that's the solution for this
conflict that's the ones that we need to
empower that's where we need to put the
funds on people like that who know that
when there's a fire let's go and turn it
off together and yeah as opposed to
those who think that if they flame if
they start the flames they will bring
the kinds you want to continue with this
belligerent occupation of yours
literally and endlessly I'm using the
words that the height your own high
court used because as they said in 2004
the general point of departure of all
parties here which is also our point of
departure is that Israel holds the area
in belligerent occupation until it is
your court until it's your court
it is my court I'm only quoting your
court accident I'm happy that you're
quoting my court and I'm proud that this
is my court because this court can have
that opinion and on the other hand say
that I'm entitled to live in a fraud
because of the international law the way
we interpret it now
well your Supreme Court has never ruled
on that your Supreme Court has never
ruled on whether the settlement movement
is legal the that's a fact they have
ruled endless endless rulings about
houses that are retired dividual houses
individual houses I've know the legality
of the circle so maybe file that
petition and see what they rule okay
maybe do a study cave already they've
already said it's none jus just dis your
body it's not for within the purview
core by on the other hand on the other
hand they have ruled that houses can
stay towns can be established cities can
be building your belligerent occupation
our belligerent occupation if you want
me to repeat your questions in your
accusations it won't make it any
stronger we own a pretty strong
accusation by itself it could be it is
it could be at the end of the day the
situation the legal situation in Judea
and Samaria is the unique one which
there is absolutely no resemblance
anywhere else in the world for the basic
fact that the countries which held this
area of land prior to 1967 have signed
in writing a waiver that they have no
more claims over this land and therefore
the only future plan declaration
understanding as to the title of this
land will be reached according to
international understanding and
agreement and yet those who didn't read
the Camp David Accords in 1972 David
Accords what were they based on they
were based on resolution 242 which
provides explicitly for the withdrawal
of Israeli forces from land they had
taken in the recent conflict and this
was in 1968 so the recent conflict
referred to 67 when you occupied these
lands and Israel signed up to that and
ratified that because it ratified it
along with the Egyptian bomb you
accepted it and you have violated it
ever since I think your interpretation
of these two sections of the United
Nations resolution is misleading because
that's not the way we interpret it and
withdrawal of forces means what that you
stay there for the next 50 years an
occupation did it mean now I don't think
it meant that I think at the end of the
day it said that what has to be done
needs to be done with international
understanding and acceptance and as long
as there is no international
understanding and acceptance and because
Israel today holds already expert legal
opinions that say that we have the
rights to live and build in Judea and
Samaria and because the Palestinians
have basically refused every single
compromise up until today we're in a
situation where we are
he is much stronger than policy and
that's where we are today and and much
stronger than agreements you've already
signed but mr. Ravi V so what do we look
forward to one stay the two-state
solution as you said is going nowhere so
we have one state in which Jewish
Israelis have full political rights here
and where millions of Palestinians don't
is that what is that but what's what's
coming here no I don't think that's
what's coming I think that's a very
old-school thought a which is very fixed
on the question whether we're for one
state or for a two-state solution I
think it is time that we sit in a room
and try and find a third option an
option that the Palestinians will feel
satisfied with an option that will give
the Israeli government and the Israeli
people the safety and the peace that
we're looking for they're looking for a
state you know what they'd be satisfied
with they've said it they want a
sovereign state not a state - like Prime
Minister Netanyahu has offered them nor
as your Education Minister mr. Bennet
wants to do which is to take away the
last vestiges of Hope which he said
specifically take away the last vestiges
of hope that any Palestinian will ever
get a sovereign state you you want you
in that camp - no you're not I think we
are trying different experiments with
the Palestinians unfortunately every
single experiment has failed up till now
God experimenting giving them some right
Gaza was an experiment they have full
rights I think let's speak about what
we've tried up until now back in the
West Bank okay want to talk about the
West Bank let's talk about the West Bank
you know you tell them you tell them
let's progress you have a thousand
working alkylated on thousand Palestine
can I complete it I thought you asked me
a question I didn't I didn't see any
question mark but let me try an answer
please we're running out of K in Judea
and Samaria 1993-1994 the Oslo accord
there was an attempt to establish a
Palestinian state the truth of the
matter is the Palestinian Authority has
all the elements of an independent state
besides - they don't have a declaration
of independence and they don't have an
army they have their own elective system
they have their own elected people they
have their own judicial
system they have their own police they
have their own jails they have their own
tax system and they're under an occupier
and it's coming up to 15 years of
occupation
we are not distinct when they cannot no
you're not disturbing that why they like
you can go into their down car their
homes
anytime you I can't they elect any time
they want why can't they elect because
they have decided to postpone elections
time after time after time
Israel allowed for open free elections
to happen in Gaza and look what we ended
up with Hamas mr. Riebe we're running
out of time
it's be a pleasure to have you on
conflict sir likewise thank you thank
you come again
[Music]
you
[Music]